first up he's the 29-time emmy-winning
broadcaster for the mlb network and host
of the new show
back on the record with bob costas
coming to hbo
this summer bob costas is back here and
back on the network
tamala
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't get that i thought we all agreed
and i found out how wrong i am
having been out getting covered
that's probably how i got i've been out
yeah people
went right back to the shaking in the
hand and the hugging
they people need human contact and i was
the one going
wait i thought we had decided that even
when the pandemic is over
that was unnecessary and then they were
like oh mr negative i'm like what i was
the one guy during the whole things
pre-covered i always felt we ought to go
the asian route yeah and just bow first
of all it's more respectful
and if you shake enough hands forget
about during a pandemic
you shake enough hands you're going to
get a cold a catch or something i don't
want anyone to touch me unless they mean
business
that's always been
so this this has been a particularly
rough stretch for you hasn't it
let's talk about the olympics yeah okay
no i no i associate now i would never i
think you know this i've done jokes i've
never been a giant olympic fan
right you know i mean especially like
the girls gymnastics seems like child
abuse to you know
capture them at the age of four and
train them 12 hours a day
there's something to that yeah yeah okay
but i know rah-rah america great okay
so we kick ass overseas
um but i do associate it with you i mean
i never watched it for the games i
watched it for you
you're you are the uh games were
secondary
it was really the broadcasting you do
have a spec how many did you cover
12 12. yeah no yeah from 1988 through
2016. oh wow all right because every two
years
yeah yeah right and the the prep must be
crazy
yeah well you know i learned after the
first couple i learned that the host has
to be a good generalist
but you don't need to know every
platform diver from peru
or every cross-country skier from norway
that's for the people at the venues
just have to have the big picture well
okay so now we're
gonna have it in tokyo in just
a month yep okay this is a big
controversy
again i have no dog in this fight i
don't watch it for you
and now you're not doing it
it it frees up a lot of time it really
does it's that's what's one thing it
takes too long
there's too many back stories about what
they went through
to get there you know if they just cut
it down you know
it's like all these streaming shows that
should be just a movie just make it into
one
[ __ ] movie but they spent a billion
dollars or more for the rights
and it dominates the ratings in a time
when everything is fragmented
okay and that was one of the things that
cuts through so you think it shouldn't
take place because
we're not going to have a crowd in tokyo
it should be postponed
not cancelled right if they postponed it
till the summer of 2022
then as a one-off it would go back to
the way it was prior to the 90s was
which was that the winter and summer
games took place every four years
in the same calendar year yeah under
these circumstances it makes sense but
you got to understand
the ioc holds all the cards new england
journalists the international
international olympic committee and
every time i see their name in the
headline it's something shady
is that wrong it's not wrong they have
an affinity for
authoritarian regimes they'll be back in
beijing
for the winter olympics they were in
sochi in 2014
they were in beijing in 2008. so you're
saying we should have boycotted all
these
no the boycotts mostly hurt the athletes
rather than the government that they're
aimed at they have to work with these
governments
yeah it's a particularly difficult
tightrope walk
for nbc because unlike other entities
that cover it
the network that carries the olympics or
any sports event
has invested a lot of money in the
rights and they want people to feel good
about watching it
but my feeling always was that you need
to at least acknowledge the elephants in
the room
and i tried as best i could to tug on
the other end of that rope
but they were always very very touchy
about possibly offending
the ios wasn't china trying to get you
banned at one point
1996 even before the 08 games in beijing
1996 during the opening ceremony i
pointed out the soviet union had just
broken up
that if any nation had the resources and
the motivation to replicate what the old
eastern bloc
did with systematic cheating that's not
to say that american athletes don't
cheat but they do it on their own or
with rogue
scientists not under the direction of
the usoc or the united states government
china had a motivation to do it several
athletes had already been caught
i also pointed out that they wanted to
host the 2000 olympics this is before
they got
the 08 olympics 2000 olympics went to
sydney australia
but that concerns over human rights and
the threat to taiwan and all the rest
had scotched their uh their bid
so the internet had just started but
there was a campaign directed
by beijing to have me fired unless
i issued a public apology in prime time
you could have neither of which happened
you could have been patient zero for
getting cancelled
yeah yeah but you see now
putin was more stealth in 2014 in sochi
he just gave me pink eye
right so i remember that oh that was
brutal oh that was brutal it's brutal
what a trooper you were
you